the numbers just one quick question
first Victory finally how does it feel
yeah I was a little bit unexpected
[Music]
um
I finally got to experience
time travel show which is
um
you know
interesting enough
um I just think like I know that he
always spends his time like this but
sometimes you get surprised and then
poor decisions and that's what happened
like once he started to get out of
control
yeah you've had several poor decisions
to grown
wrong it's fairly easy yeah I see and
today how many autographs did you give
on your way to coming here because we
saw one guy took selfie with you how
does it feel like to go walking in
Warsaw
no sir I mean people are are nice so
usually like in between games and such I
prefer to keep on my own but I'm
generally happy to oblige after games
yeah and last question which is
interested for everybody like about your
hairstyle is it some kind of bed or
something yeah
two greyhounds yes how far we go we'll
see thank you